this just in gang we are going to be a
part of the new york comedy fest here in
new york city november 9th you can get
tickets to come and see us at gotham
comedy club november 9th gonna be a
fantastic time yes and also don't forget
october 27th we're going home baby the
boys are going back to philly helium
comedy club one show only get tickets
that's close to selling out new york's
gonna sell out philly's gonna sell out
let's go get your tickies
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
r u garbage sure is it's a little show
we sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find that i think you're to be
classy yeah or if they're just a big old
piece of trash you don't say i'm your
host holy coming at you on a beautiful
day we're down here at auntie's basement
she's a little upset with the boss today
with me yeah don't play dumb what what
did i do well you know she's a big fall
girl she's a big october girl she loves
halloween spice everything now you can
spice everything nice she went to the
store yeah yeah over there
picked up a box of those ginger snaps
and now they're gone we know you have a
fetish for them buddy so don't play
stupid hippie likes a nice gingy snap
but he double you dip that in a little
bit of hot cocoa till it breaks apart
good knocks i tell you what you want to
connect with your irish heritage have a
couple ginger snaps and a cup of tea
with a little milk in it
a little bit of bailey's too if you're
talking my irish heritage
spice it up a bit my co-host is coming
at you from right next to me he is the
ceo of are you garbage he's
international businessman do me a favor
give me a nice big round of applause for
the one the only mr kevin james ryan hey
hey hey gang hey buddy thanks for having
me oh don't be silly good to see you
glad it worked out uh thanks for tuning
in everybody i appreciate all support uh
if you haven't already please make sure
you rate review and subscribe on itunes
those numbers are cooking
uh and then full video available on
youtube and as you know those numbers
are true
true the [ __ ] room i'm sorry i'm
interrupt but we got cooking we got
through the roof that's everything right
i feel like there's another
website platform media company that we
we work on that's so funny i got to tell
you about this awesome website i just
found it's called patreon.com and it
makes you a millionaire
it's unbelievable and we love you shout
out to patreon.com the am family all the
yam subsidiaries ham yams whatever you
need i'm in i'm your i'm a company boy
sweet lord watch over them
sweet deer babies all that money
man ow and how about a nice quick shout
out to our producer extraordinaire he's
a magic man he makes us all look good
the man behind a lot of the videos all
the videos that you see that you love
with us tebow mcmuffin toby macbone
what's up dudes hey bone just you know
in here working on a football sunday
like a real good employee don't forget
it
when it comes time to write them checks
i'm a venmo man working on a sunday um i
want to say something real quick what's
that in the business room i don't mean
to step on your toes buddy is this a
board are we having our first public
board meeting talking about patreon
talking up what's that talking about
patreon.com never heard of it backslash
are you garbage
for bonus content yes now one of the
things that we've been doing is fat
court yes right yes trying to get uncle
hank situated sure we had a couple of
real passionate real funny episodes with
fat court yes a couple of tears were
shed we just brought you just brought me
back in on church
for the for the for the non-patreon
listener we we did fat court a few
months ago and uh
you were released on probation yeah on
your own you know on your own accord
right back to my old ways
[Laughter]
he's a born criminal folks i'm like the
ice pop man
so i let you out off on your own and
then we had a little probationary
checkup i sent the parole officer over
to your house start poking around yeah i
think that pulmonologist gave you a call
started running his mouth because when i
was at the cardiologist a few months ago
i was 3.85 and all sometimes
thanksgiving giving out all the patreon
details goddamn what the [ __ ]
well talked about pulmonology he's not
three he's not 385 anymore news flash
breaking the break in the fourth wall
here i'll give you a little you're gonna
know you're fat you idiot
i think they know so fat court is back
fat court's back all i wanted to say
check it out it's absolutely it's
absolutely a great time and everybody we
love you yeah yeah uh-huh i don't know
where the i love you came from i know
yeah yeah yeah just you panic when the
lights get on i do
fly me to the moon i got a roach in the
fridge
um before we get started gang as you
know there's a family up we're going to
be answering your questions
here live
live to tape in front of a studio
audience that's only t-boned
um
i i think i've mentioned this to you
before but what do you got for some
reason it's becoming more and more
prevalent that i'm realizing that i do
it and i have to do it and i think it's
garbage but i bet you there's a lot of
people out there that also do it okay
when i brush my teeth yeah in the shower
yes can you use a nerd's robe
you guys using fun dip
when i brush my teeth
and i want to say that my brother has
this same affliction too from hearing
him brush his teeth um like when we were
living together if i was in my room gag
yourself i feel i gag my i can't i'm not
satisfied with the brush
until i do my tongue with the toothbrush
and then i have to go back so far
whereas i gag myself which every once in
a while leads me to throwing up
and then i gotta brush my teeth all over
again but is that a thing
that you brush your tongue until you do
you do a little gag and then you feel
like you got everything
yeah i hate it though you do not not
every time not every time
if i'm really getting back there because
i did some damage the night before it's
i hate that feeling what's some [ __ ]
doing a tongue scraper did you ever do
one of those take the paint off the
walls yeah i'm saying
it's something you're like how is that
it's too much how do you not smell that
it's too much i don't i don't get it
like bologna on a honda she's just
killed right off too much i don't get
i'm like it comes out like icing and
then you're like you s you you then take
a whiff of that cause i'm a guy
i'm a sniffer i'm a big sniffer i'm
sniffing pretty much anything yes i put
on a nice thing here you know i i act
disgusted at what you do
but i i'm sniffing poop on the finger
i'm i'm taking a run at it not anymore
really as a kid i would dabble yeah
anymore i know i've been i've been to
the other side i've walked on the moon i
know what it smells like i go right to
the sink
ah cheesesteak with onions um man we got
it we were in the [ __ ] slop right
away at this one his mother was a this
one's duty his father was a mother
we're just being honest yeah folks
that's what it is a real deal
[Laughter]
boasts pretentious toilet humor um
i you know what what i it's kind of it's
weird i'm going to open up right we're
in the trust tree here of course we are
um i'm a big uh i like to get a whiffer
uh
look how
happy he is
is it the taint no cause i'm also a
connoisseur
don't act like you ain't
i'm not for something that's so dirty
why does that area smell like bleach i
don't get it i i stay away
from
that area i don't go i don't go whiffing
anyway i know what i know what's there
i've been there like i've said i don't
need it again okay okay i've had enough
i've chased the dragon
but what i'll do is uh you're in gym
class getting high on your own balls
ryan get out of here
ryan knock that off
[Laughter]
sorry man all the basketballs smell like
fermented cheese you got pubes all over
your face you had pubes in high school
um
yeah i would yeah that was a joke okay
all right
got pubes yeah i would hope you had
pubes in high school be weird if you
were driving what a [ __ ] what a bear
with a bald eagle down there
it's a pre-wreck to get your your
learner's permit
um
[ __ ] where was i oh
oh the floss i get the thing and i'll
smell the plaque on my fl all my floss
yeah
wait what you just talked about smelling
your [ __ ] dude
and the poop that gets on your first of
all i didn't know plaque smelled give it
a whirl
buddy you want your hair blown back on a
saturday before you head out ah i hate
that the the little things rotting tooth
smells one of the worst oh it's not
rotting tooth but it's like uh i love
those
i forget jesus most of you is rotting
um
the the picks like the individual floss
jaws there's one called glide and
there's another one called slide to try
to rip them off but those things that
have the shank on the end of it
yeah are dangerous you gotta get glide
though it's like oral b glide it it's
like orgasmic when it gets in there it
really slips in doesn't bleed it's
it's i don't know what it's like nasa i
don't know what it's made out of but
nothing else comes close to it i like a
good toothpick like like picking of the
teeth yeah go do a little session while
you're watching oh yeah my dad was big
with a matchbook he'd rip a little piece
out and sit there yeah while we're
watching night court maybe 18 or
something like that i remember my fourth
grade teacher mr bennett used to open up
a paper clip and then dig in his ear and
i remember thinking even then i'm like
that seems a little bonko's
right like you're playing with how's the
divorce going big guy because you're not
even supposed to do q-tips anymore let
alone getting in there with a [ __ ]
little needle [ __ ] digging around
[ __ ] yeah that's insane do your guys
gums bleed when you brush and floss not
brush if i'm
flossing
it depends uh
the how vigorous i am but yeah i mean
for sure brushing though never that's
the one thing that i've always done
every day i don't know why i do it
i don't know how i keep up with it
without any effort or whatever i wish i
could apply this to every other aspect
keeping the tires clean on a hooptie but
i can't i floss every single time i
brush my teeth i floss dude i look like
apollo creed later on canvas dude that's
bad man talk to my mom patty's
straighten them out yeah she'll be
losing it i'll be getting calls about
that you gotta tell tell me that bosses
stink i do i floss a handful of times a
week i wouldn't say it's every day but
probably 70 you know maybe like four or
five times a week um
it depends on the schedule if i'm
running late whatever um
but
uh i remember i went to the last dentist
i went to she's like do you floss every
day and i was like
no i'm like most days which is probably
pretty good for most people aren't
flossing every day
anybody is yeah
stop just sitting on the shelves um
i was like most days she's like most
days isn't good enough like first of all
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] you talking about
most like hey most days and she's like
she goes you gotta do it every day i go
yeah i try she goes well do you eat
every day i'm like yeah she's like then
you can fall asleep i'm like eating the
flossing aren't the same [ __ ] thing
lady once you start making floss out of
chicken butter maybe i'll [ __ ] think
about it
what are we doing here
miss your question do i dump my floss in
a nice marinara
yeah
take a hike
so you're not a gagger
no i'll get in there you're a guy i
don't go too deep occasionally yeah yeah
i don't go too i'd be interested to know
what the the bozos shout out
the bozos what what the squad what the
gang thinks of that there's got to be
some gaggers out there
i believe
i brought this up in casual conversation
in the green room one time and our good
friend mr matt richards previous guest
on the show
that he i i i'm pretty sure it was him i
don't get that you have to have that
feeling but i could be wrong
it's not for me not for me yeah
it's bad yeah i blew out a blood vessel
in my eye one time doing it
because i did it and i uh and i
popped it
popped a circle all right all right okay
i mean you're that's crazy that's
you always take it a little too far oh
i'm sorry flaw sniffer judging me no i'm
just saying and now i'm not saying on
the show i'm saying in life you got to
fly that close to the sun where you're
popping blood vessels that's what i'm
saying i like it there's it's never
enough for you and anything food drugs
burnies
i don't know what it is yeah i got to
get real close
yeah i like it right there on the edge
rise from the ashes playing chicken
with a chicken
sandwich
now what that is some business yeah this
is a family episode family up folks so
uh as you know uh when it's just me to
big man and t-bone um they're family
apps and we answer your patreon your
garbage questions as you ask on patreon
it's the best way to do it sometimes we
throw in a couple of igs maybe dm
maybe the facebooks and stuff but maybe
um you know we're running through the
patreon queues and we got some heaters
this one's and since we're in a bathroom
right we're in the bathroom yes we are
let's talk about it this is from chris
uh what is the current status of your
shower curtain
i [ __ ] hate it that's the currency
the lady likes to you know she does
everything really nice she knows all the
sure the broads know what they're doing
they do however
sometimes
uh we get in a situation at the foley
household where it's fashion over
function
we want it she wants it to look nice so
as you know growing up the inside shower
curtain was always hardcore plastic on
the inside of course it's got to be
waterproof right
the the
the the trend now is to get like cloth
ones that are nice oh my mom has that
the hotels have them
take
a hike
with that yeah it's all over the floor i
get out i'm [ __ ] slipping and sliding
yeah i was no good for the big guy yeah
i mean when i'm in there
it it's like you're washing an elephant
oh really i've requested more as a
meerkat kind of guy i i've i've
requested
[Laughter]
i've requested the bar that goes out a
little bit
but that got vetoed quickly two guys in
safari hats scraping your hooves
uh
a dentist tries to shoot you i'm chewing
on a palm tree
yeah
you can't this goes back to fat court
you can't be altering you know the
structure of your house to fit you i
want the the the slider
i want the the one you can't see through
the old school glass
glass yeah my dad the one one of the
houses my dad rented after the divorce
those things get shitty real quick after
like three showers
yeah yeah yeah but right now we got
the cloth one like a white cloth one and
then like the clear plastic not like the
old school hot but like a plastic liner
yes cause you got gotta have the
waterproof on the inside you got to we
got that and uh
my lady's been visiting family for the
past handful of weeks and that thing i
haven't taken a run past that thing is
dirty oh it's
it's got black mold green mold brown
whatever you want it's like here's the
good news it's not great here's the good
news get rid of that two seconds
not cleaning it no yeah yeah cleaning
[ __ ] rip that down that's a sandwich
bag to me what are you talking about
that's what i'm saying those are condoms
as far as there are shower condoms that
thing's getting thrown out and i'll tell
you what we were saying i gotta do it we
were such garbage when we were kids that
i remember like every single time that
my mom got a new shower curtain oh boy
like it was great oh it was a thing yeah
like one had like fishes on it and like
he always felt dishes fish fish it
always felt so fresh and clean in there
the smell of the plastic
don't you love that shooting some blanks
all over that thing
smell a new jellyfish on that bad boy
love that it's like a new car smell do
you guys have like a real new york setup
for your tub i got a sideways shower
it's no good i got mom sideways now
buddy that [ __ ]
i'm sideways that's like something in
the corners office
that that is such just got the chain
that you
i've seen those sideways showers for
folks that don't live in the city what
is it it's it's literally in the middle
of the tub on the wall and the tub's
going the other way
yeah take a hike i got one of those now
it comes with roaches i got one of those
now um
but
the good thing is my shower head so the
shower head's in the middle which is
nice and it's a bit it's like a it's
like a [ __ ]
it's like a sewer cap it's a big man
pajama okay so the whole middle of the
thing is watered oh straight down not
you don't you have a rainfall yeah yeah
yeah yeah you don't have to [ __ ]
it's not coming in on an angle so you
got to like you know you don't have to
move your body ever you're just [ __ ]
in it you're wet you're wet i like a
rainfall but i need some power this
thing's this thing cooks it does it yeah
yeah i got i got a serious mike hooks
yeah i got a serious business in this
apartment yeah this might be the best
one i've ever had in new york love it
yeah love a nice hot specially now fall
this time of year you open the window
you get the cool breeze coming in the
hot shower oh you feel like you're in
sweden or something like that
iceland
here it feels like you're in a hot
iceland iceland iceland iceland iceland
yeah because because my one of my guests
are going to water land
my garbage one of my garbage dreams is i
want to be in a hot tub while it's
snowing
i've i've done that right you've done
that yeah when i went to recently for my
anniversary when i got stuck in the
snowstorm remember that the the infamous
woodlock
yeah
kind of pepperage farm yeah yeah outdoor
lockwood the spas at lockwood woodlock
yeah woodlock sounds like a prison okay
state not federal
work release
uh
yeah it was fantastic but that just
brought back a memory of buying
uh obviously before this podcast we were
a couple of real poor bazzos i mean like
you wouldn't even recognize this
couple of losers uh real
end up on money and for a long time we
were cash poor for a long time i had an
mp i had an airbnb in my apartment i
remember you were like locking up your
silverware in your closet so i would say
somebody got in too yeah i think a
couple of these two broads from kentucky
came up smoked a bunch of meth i think
uh-huh
broke into my closet it sounds like a
nice little week pour everything apart
so let's all right let me back up a
second i just have to airbnb
my before my wife moved here we had an
apartment and she would was traveling
back and forth for like months at a time
and when she was gone to cover rent i
would have to airbnb my apartment
because you can make like 400 bucks on
the weekend for it and turn a trick or
two
i wear my boys my little booty shorts no
kissing so no kissing kippy i would have
to airbnb my apartment
and they're having a good time i know
uh i had to uh
it was i it was
my shower curtain was so filthy like
filthy filthy filthy okay and i had
these people coming
like that they were coming in like three
hours or something so i'm like
frantically trying to clean the
apartment so it's the people not coming
in some [ __ ] mess
and uh
my shower curtain was just like [ __ ]
because i was living on my own for like
four months at that but it's just not
good batch like not even what it is i
don't know what it is it should be
waterproof
that's strange
that's where you would that's where
that's where a new civilization would
form
i remember i'm sitting there and i'm
like i didn't have they're like what
seven bucks at like one of those corner
like you know discount dollars three
seconds she got one i didn't have the
money jesus didn't have the money so i i
sat there and started scrubbing the
[ __ ] put a sleeping bag over it i'm
in the shower
it's not on but i'm in the shower like
wearing like jeans and [ __ ] like
scrubbing the inside to get the [ __ ]
should've just got rid of it because
i've done it and then i wouldn't have
one thing then you just put the other
one on the inside i only was only
rocking one
just one plastic
i was airbnb in my apartment i didn't
have you were only rocking one you only
had the liner i didn't yeah jesus
i didn't have dual [ __ ] curtain money
it's like sleeping with no sheets
which is nice sometimes kip let's talk
about butcher box what's your box yup
got back from uh san antone yeah all
right what was waiting for me there a
huge box so meat enormous box of
delicious grass-fed
unbelievable meat ground beef steak tips
steaks a whole chicken organic
free-range chickies crazy yeah chops the
whole nine yards it's all in our freezer
we take it out in the morning when we
want to have it for dinner it's
unbelievable you got to get on butcher
box i'm telling you yeah guys we're
living the time butcher boxes giving new
members
write this down call your mom whatever
you need to do is giving new members two
pounds of free ground beef in every
order for the life of your membership
hello police i'd like to report a
robbery imagine never having to shop for
ground beef again baby and i gotta tell
you i got about 50 pounds in my freezer
and it ain't just ground beef it's the
good stuff because it has that it has
that real real red color to it it's
great it feels it's a no-brainer once
you signed up you choose your box and
delivery frequency they offer five boxes
four curated box options as well as the
custom one you get exactly what you want
your whole family's gonna love it
ships butcher box ships your order
frozen at peak freshness and packed at
100
recyclable box shipping is always free
enjoy great tasting high quality meat
delivered right to your door yeah
fantastic this is your choice to never
this is your chance to never have to
shop for ground beef again butcher box
is giving new members free ground beef
for life free ground beef for life sign
up at butcherbox.com ag and get two
pounds of ground beef in every order for
the life of your membership log on to
butcherbox.com ag to claim this deal do
it how about our good friends over there
at stamps.com love em we don't show them
enough love we gotta show them some love
right now because they save you time
they save you money you don't want to
waste time hanging out in the post
office when you can do it all from your
office we're a small business you're a
small business okay get on stamps.com
straighten these bozos out uh yeah
stamps.com brings the service of the u.s
postal service and ups shipping right to
your computer you just need a computer a
printer the internet can do it from your
car your house rv boat whatever you got
they'll do it and whether you got a side
hustle etsy full blown warehouse
there you go if you're hustling trying
to make ends meet we do the merch the
whole nine yards it's fantastic do the
merch right here throw it all in bags
bring it down to the post office dump it
in the bin we're outside catching a
bernie in about two minutes row and go
baby there's no risk and with our promo
code garbage you get a special offer
that includes a four-week trial plus
free postage and a digital scale they
sent us the package easy peasy lemon
squeezy peasy no long-term commitments
or contracts required just go to
stamps.com click the microphone at the
top of the home page uh type in garbage
at stamps.com promo code
garbagestamps.com never go to the post
office again kippy i got a word for you
manscaped manscaped baby come on
4.0 lawnmower uh-huh we're talking
ceramic blades what we're talking
powerful yet quiet motor we're talking
light so you can see what you're doing
down there spotlight we're talking
waterproof
manscaped you got to get on it
unbelievable yeah guys with the manscape
performance package 4.0 inside the
package you'll find the lawnmower 4.0
trimmer which fully just ran down for
you fantastic prank oh i forgot yeah you
get the weed whacker ear nose and ear
nose and hair trimmer crop preserver
ball deodorant crop reviver toner when
you want a tight sack easy i'm a tight
sack man myself okay performance uh
boxer briefs which are top-notch travel
bag to hold all your stuff guys what are
we doing you know manscaped get involved
with these guys ladies if you're
listening get involved with these guys
perfect gift for the for the homies yeah
for the boys for the men a lady couldn't
lady yeah no well a lady wants her man
ah lady wants the man to keep it neat
clean i also just saw manscaped on shark
tank shout out you're on my favorite
show really saw when we were in texas so
technically we were on shark tank
manscaped even threw in two free gifts
to the performance package the the the
travel bag the boxes the whole nine
yards so guys this is what you do i use
that i'm sorry to cut you off i use that
travel bag all the time that is a we i
would call that a shaving kit back yeah
yeah yeah for sure unbelievable
fantastic so guys you get 20 off plus
free shipping with promo code garbage at
manscape.com that's 20 off plus free
shipping with the code garbage at
manstop.com make your balls a priority
this fall choose manscape your balls
will thank you now back to the show yeah
wow
those were dark times yes they were then
those those two broads i so i would lock
up i had my closet in my room i would
lock up closet in the living room i
would lock up and it was more of like
you could open that you could [ __ ]
rip it open if you wanted to but it's
like
if you do that you're sealed yeah you're
just sh it's a seal going like i clearly
broke into your thing yeah so they got
in somehow
they took the tools that were under like
the sinkers i had like a drill and they
drilled off the [ __ ] locks of the
wall great very smart very smart got in
there got her just like tore through all
my [ __ ] [ __ ] like everything
and then i figured they were [ __ ]
with all the electricity or metal stuff
and someone's like that's meth like they
were like
digging through looking for something i
was like oh
okay that was a sleepless night when i
got home he's [ __ ] laying in bed just
picturing he's too [ __ ] little meth
demons creeping around yeah these two
meth dog boats running around the
[ __ ] picture them like crabs
walking sideways it's my first time in
new york
well it's the last time in my apartment
keep it moving yeah i don't like that
yeah but i respect the move hey that's
why i open that's what i you know i'm
opening up my apartment to [ __ ] meth
heads from kentucky that's what happens
they were going to like the lady gaga
concert or something that's what they
told me that was the ruse and that
checks out i always had a fear too
people would be shooting porn in there
so anytime i'm looking anytime i'm
perusing the hub i was looking for my
apartment ryan family photo in the
background you making a stupid face me
on stage
so to answer your question
we keep it pretty tight over there
when when my wife's running the show
it's tired the fact that she's been gone
visiting fam it's [ __ ]
yeah any alteration to that situation
it's it's it's you can't leave me in my
own device yeah i'm carrying there's
just because
if you only have one it's got to be on
the inside if you have two do it the
smart way
stop trying to look cool yeah it's st
west elm street or whatever it is i
believe freddy krueger west elm street
um all right this one
i did last night
this is from blaine do you pee in
parking lots oh yeah did it last night
love it it's a freeing feeling peeing
outside's the best peeing in the grass i
do it all the time when i'm at my
parents house and i have to take the dog
out to the little dog run where she goes
pee pee and poopy um dog run is a is a
loose term too you know what it is
you've seen that where the filled up
that is a piss corner yeah that's not i
mean that's not a dog run she usually
there's no grass there she is like
broken seashells
it's
old metal cans yeah that's not a that's
not a a dog run has like a house and of
and you know something that ain't a dog
we should get our little doggy house
back there but then she wouldn't be
inside and we need our snuggles um
but when i take her back there i'll i'll
go we almost descended into foleyville
real quick we uh i i always pee why she
pees
feels great love it yeah
yeah yeah
feels really good parking lots
after a ball game you got a bunch of
beers in you even last night we were in
this we're gonna we went to the show
we're in the
suburb connecticut suburban connecticut
quiet not a building in sight walk over
to the [ __ ] ground by the moonlight
takes you back to childhood oh i used to
pee i love it just whip it out and pee
it's nice um
i can't i can't hold my i can't hold my
pee anymore that's one thing i guess
getting older i can't really like when i
gotta pee i gotta [ __ ] you gotta go
yeah and when i pee it is the greatest
feeling of all time
it's awesome
peeing in your 40s is
it's like two weeks vacation it's
fantastic it's currently doing a bit
folks
theoretically
it didn't work on stage so he polished
it up it's becoming a bit but it's a
genuine sentiment
which i feel entitled that i can discuss
here sure in this arena of course
i'll give you some notes afterwards i
used to work part-time as a waiter
waitress waitress
don't even know your own bits
that's how out the lunch you are
um this one um this is from kemper i've
ne this is you know
uh have you ever been pulled over more
than once more than once in one night
that's a bad one
you're in a you're you're in a bad way
with some bad people if that's happening
that means that you have something on
your car that isn't legal tense you
gotta light it out yeah light out
turn signal stop bad turn signal
that's uh yeah but or yeah that ain't no
or or you're in a small town and the
guys johnny law's got it out for you
true might have you know you might have
diddled his his girlfriend before they
said they linked up or some high school
beef yeah
kind of like i'm a sheriff now yeah
these tents are too dark real rainbow
stuff get out of my town exactly keep an
eye on that guy it has a loose cannon
um now yeah garbage um this one i had i
had a i had a run in with today where i
had a moral um
this is from clark stealing from the
checkout or nah
no what are you stealing from the
checkpoint i don't steal like the
self-checkout
no i'm not i i'm not giving them the
satisfaction
of some bozo
of course of course and i don't like the
security guard in the front door that
checks your receipt
i don't understand that what are you
going to go through all my bags yeah
kick rocks i get that it's it's you know
it's an honest day's work i get it sure
have that guy pushing a broom or
something i think it's like home depot
they look at it and like hit it with a
highlighter it's like that's you know
you don't know what you're doing yeah
um
but today in my supermarket uh they
installed these they pay like two months
ago what the self checkout they got rid
of three checkouts and put in three self
checkouts three jobs going
so i'm like
uh
[Music]
i don't like them
i don't know they're not great typically
if you're walking to like a proper
walmart target or whatever i don't mind
hitting them in and out real [ __ ]
these are sometimes they're stupid these
like all the products are in because
it's like it's a mom and pop super put
it in the bag it is in the bag it's not
hey please gotta wait for help and this
unidentified object in the bagging area
kick rock and that guy the person that
patrols that yeah they're always the
worst yeah because they didn't want to
do the regular checkout
they took the self-checkout spot yeah on
the shift sure so they didn't have to
[ __ ] deal with anybody yeah i don't
know if they're picking now they're
coming over at a car and they walk away
so today i i've been avoiding them
because like everybody when you're
waiting in line everybody so there's
like you can go to like the regular
cashiers it's like the same line and
when you get up there it's like you can
go and no one uses them because they're
not great like
bananas aren't in there you're like not
everything's [ __ ] in there it's good
you know your codes you can put your
codes in 4011 408.88 hit me with
something i know the code broccoli
408.88 check that shampoo shampoo
there's no code to shampoo why not it's
produce [ __ ] it's just kiwi
4080
oh parsnip not that one cilantro
red beans cilantro all those are all
scans typically on the thai they have
the oranges
broccoli crowns 38 though
uh oranges this big sun-kissed oranges i
believe are 48 uh
40-88 granny smith apples
bread delicious honey crisp mountain dew
four six six cantalouper
yeah i know though i'm pretty good i got
a curveball eggplant
nobody's buying it no one's buying
russian potatoes dude to get this
no one's buying what eggplant not that
regularly it's not like [ __ ] bananas
i think i have more eggplant here than i
do have bananas love an eggplant parm
yeah but you're not buying it and making
it you're not making eggplant parm at
the house the lady does
not as much as you're eating it what was
the last meal you
cooked that i could like i personally
cooked
i think i took some different leftover
chinese and made a little that's not
cooking made a little i made a little
that's being hungry at 3 a.m that's not
cook good time now take all your chinese
leftovers put them in the one saute pan
with a little bit of water give it a
couple of flips
look out
[ __ ] general chow's low main fried
rice
fantastic
it's it all works i don't know why yeah
if you do it right it works
um but i'm checking out today and it's
all the guy goes here use this one i go
now i'm going to wait and i was like
next time i just use like and i'm like
all right i'll [ __ ] i'll use it grow
yourself check out it's going chasing
you around the store
this thing's gone rogue it's not
reading the one thing i'm buying the
eggs or whatever the [ __ ] it was just
like this this thing's not in this
product's not a product not identified
so i'm like ah come over and he's like
i'll try it again i'm like it i just
scan it's not going to now know it
scan it again now so he's got to redo
the code so i'm like so now he's got to
enter the [ __ ] you know 299 or
whatever the [ __ ] it is
and i was just i was so mad and then i
was gonna i wanted to steal because then
it's an honor system on how many bags
you need because you got to pay for the
bags in new york now yeah which ought to
steal the bag
just out just out of spice but i love it
you make me do it and then the [ __ ]
thing doesn't work but i love those bags
i have ten i throw them out because we
have so many yeah i don't think that's
solving the plastic bag problem because
now you just have a nicer bag that
you're gonna use one to throw away yeah
but it's not plastic that's the idea it
is plastic
isn't that plastic on the outside
what is that shiny part on the outside
oh you're like you're talking about like
those properly mine has like uh
more
it's like paper like cloth ah yeah those
are pretty sweet yeah i thought that was
plastic too you're a puzzle so what'd
you did you steal it i didn't but i
wanted to and i i don't like stealing as
as the listener knows i'm an honest man
toby get me down the barrel i'm an
honest man i don't steal
uh
never really stole anything a whole
bunch i say don't give him the
satisfaction on that
i'm just yeah i just yes but it was
frustrating to say the least let me ask
you this hey buddy pretty garbage ask me
something if you've done it in the last
10 years it's trashy have you ever
picked up a magazine at the checkout in
the grocery store
of late no or a magazine in general
flying
years ago i think i would be like
i'll grab one just to like a maximum you
dirt bag
you're sitting on a plane reading a
maximum you're that's there's families
there little kids running they show
boobs on the screens
do they
and the european flights yeah they get
real kinky they show those in orange
juice commercials over there
now things are good things yeah those
euros playing fast and loose i don't
give a [ __ ]
what did i watch on the way home i can't
remember ooh goonies watch goonies on
the way home from i know it was right
next to you yeah i was a half a seat
away from you
and that's a fat joke folks
boom yeah
uh
all right this one this one i've been
wanting to bring up because there's been
some some new developments uh this is
from sideshow bub
great name uh
and obviously it says do you buy any
clothing at walmart
you're a big george guy
uh
george george's walmart i was thinking
isn't george kmart no georgia's walmart
i have barry is kmart i have a barry
collection
i have rotated out of the george
collection
why oh because dude doesn't fit
doesn't fit me george only goes up to
three
man of my stature i require a four maybe
it's not stature girth i would say
a man of your girth
a man of my
perpetuity obesity obesity
you will be paid in obesity georgia's no
good george is no good
quality wise though love it it's so
funny i'll get back there this is what i
want to do i want i wanted to bring up i
was hanging out i'm trying to find good
teas i was always just a big h m guy
because i never really had money and
they're six bucks and it was whatever i
don't like spending money on clothes
but you know they
we're wearing the [ __ ] out of them we're
traveling a bunch you know just
so
i wanted to find new tees so i you know
online bought them they were good for
like two washes and i'm like they were
like fresh teas or whatever you know
what i mean the manly tea or whatever
[Music]
bought them
whatever not good i sold my buddy i go
what tea is that i go he goes
i go because i'm in the market for some
new teas i'm looking for a new t and he
goes hey cool dude real cool dude really
real cool dude yeah george one of no one
of my coolest buddies i go what kind of
tea is it he goes you'll never guess he
goes i go where'd he get he goes take a
guess he goes i've tried them from all
over all over i tried hundreds of brands
george collection at walmart he goes
they're adorable they fit well they
don't shrink or they shrink to the right
and then they stop they don't keep going
some of the h m ones they go through the
wash once and then it's a belly shirt
you're like what i didn't put on 19
pounds market here folks i told you a
year ago you did you were shout out to
the george collection you were ahead of
the george i'll give you that at all
you're wearing george now i'll give you
another little inside tip all right you
can call your broker and tell them
[Laughter]
target has a brand called goodfellas or
good friends or uh good fellows yes it
used to be massimo i believe really yeah
well our friend brendan sagalo was
wearing that i talked to him i go what
kind of tea is that he goes goodfellow
yes they make all of my cargo joggers
and orthopedic socks and orthopedic
socks yeah but the cargo joggers that i
wear are only a double x so for you big
boys out there they're they they run up
the edit they run a bit bigger i like
them if you're in a double x
yeah oh yeah they're huge so you can
they're nice and they're comfy are they
manufactured pluto what the [ __ ] you a
double x double x
yeah
double x baby but i wear them skinny i
wore them tight
sure
like to show off the uh
merchandise and the pee spots
i got a couple
that's what's tough when you go al
fresco when i don't look camo in the
crotch i gotta be honest with you when i
don't wear like desert stored cameras
when i don't wear undies the dribble
goes right right right through it see
when you have underneath yeah wear
undies you're not wearing undies
man
fat cord folks
[Music]
yeah i am what i am so george collection
shout out to george i'm gonna give it a
whirl
and i don't want this to be i'm stealing
your style or anything but as far as
like socks underwear sweatpants um
uh a huge fluorescent t-shirt get all
that [ __ ] at [ __ ] walmart
why wouldn't you shotgun cooler
bicycle yeah i just don't find myself at
work they stopped the shotguns didn't
they
i don't know
certain parts of the country maybe maybe
not
or these have bow and arrows in there i
thought that was the coolest thing i got
my wrist rocket at kmart really oh man
yeah the marksman those things were
downright dangerous
killed somebody yeah killed i did kill
got people really yeah had it coming
look at you american sniper
the kevin ryan story
the eight-year-old story popped out of
the treehouse i had the wrist rockets i
had a glow gun that i got the
pennsylvania state fair jesus blow dart
gun
with the actual like sharp needle
what the [ __ ] i was i was in i was an
outdoorsman oh you chase an
archaeologist in the jungle what the
[ __ ] is that
the kid got it if you know you know
yeah too bad you don't speak
um
yeah i had to blow gut blow dark on
paintball gun wrist rocket
i was a real dennis the menace type guy
yeah what are you [ __ ] nelson muntz
over here jesus christ who's that oh man
this kid
cool check this guy's [ __ ] passport
yeah we got to take this kid to pop
culture school
nelson wants from the simpsons the bully
oh i didn't know his last name
sorry it's okay just didn't think he
would have still caught it on nelson
just killing the vibes yeah and the
bully thing
yeah what nelson i would have nelson
monza i thought it was like an actor
i thought he was like a character actor
wasn't even grey's anatomy yeah i'm like
that guy for me r what are we talking
about here
that's i mean
on paper you were kind of a piece of
[ __ ] of a kid what
i'm saying on paper
on paper i didn't [ __ ] come here to
have my childhood
besmirched
man i'm on the board of multiple
companies listen i said i said with all
due respect
i say with all due respect it's in the
geneva convention
[ __ ]
i'm gonna go over it with you
i'm gonna go over it with you
you ready that was the most defensive
thing i said on paper i did i'm not
saying we've been you're a lovely guy
we've been personally attacking
everybody each other for 10 years every
day fat ugly bald small pee-pee the
whole nine
that hurt me really yeah good to know
we play rough around here
that's right here we go all right guns
out let me get my blow dark you ever get
an argument with somebody that isn't a
complete psycho and it's like you know
you cross that line it's like when we i
get an argument with somebody go for the
jugular yeah i'm i don't mean anything
that i say but i'm trying to hurt you i
thought that's what i thought that's
what the dance you were sure we were
moving to yeah i thought it would say
the most the meanest thing i could
possibly
inhuman like thinking it's going to get
a lot i'd do that like no i'm talking
about real arguments like you know when
you're yelling at like your family you
don't want to hurt them no i want to
hurt them
okay i thought you just said you don't
want to hurt them i apologize no no i
don't mean what i say but i you oh yeah
you're going you're going for the you're
going for the win you're going for the
whole
yeah
so back to what i was saying
on paper as a child i i don't like this
divorce parents latch key kids just so
my parents had divorces let me have a
piece of [ __ ] you're staying together
and you stink all right
there are some evidence i mean what are
we talking about hold on stay together
for the kids ain't always good you hear
that patty go cart
i was a
my brother had a go-kart mini bike i had
a mini bike bb gun yeah blow dart sure
wrist rocket sure
paintball gun it's not like i got them
all in like a [ __ ] castle dogs that
would go missing
that's not like i picked up a [ __ ]
john wick yeah like what i didn't have
them all underneath i'm just saying man
that is th those are the things you
would i wouldn't a piece if there was a
jeopardy question what are things you
would find in a bully's garage those
items would come up that's crazy also
six cigarettes at five smoking
cigarettes at five not five
five and a half smoking cigarettes with
a wrist rocket in your hand you're up to
no good
you're lucky you became a ceo
it's like you turned your life around
what's that say about you if you if you
had it so good you're my employee what's
that say about you i was babied
oh is that what it was yeah i was baby
yeah i was baby too
i got all that cool [ __ ] you're just
jealous she didn't have the listen okay
you were babied by the hell's angels
i was i was the youngest prospect in
club history you had a pack it was it
was a patch over
you knew how to pack a brick of coke by
sixth grade
me and the cookers were down in south
philly
um i was at the community pool you were
mulling it down to florida you wouldn't
want all that [ __ ] as a kid i think this
is 100 percent this this goes to almost
100
this goes to your thing all the time
you're jealous of all the [ __ ] so you
paint it in a dark you paint it in a bad
way i i you wouldn't want to let's let's
run it you wouldn't want to go carter as
a kid i would love to go carter would
you like a mini bike as a kid
yes would you like a bb gun
yes would you like a wrist rocket i
think you start to cross the line of
at what dennis the menace
cool kid dennis the menace had a [ __ ]
slingshot yeah but made out of wood
these are the [ __ ] halliburton makes
those wrist problems oh you're not they
strapped to your arm you put a marble in
there what do you mean marble what are
you what you weren't flicking corn pops
at people pebbles you're shooting at
trees and stuff yeah that could kill
somebody
what right
you're crazy to say that that can't hurt
somebody kill somebody and hurt somebody
or a different thing oh are you talking
about one of those lungs i was a
seven-year-old i it's not like i was
[ __ ] joe rogan out here with a
stabilized bow what are you talking
about i was a seven-year-old that barely
had any upper body strength i was a fat
kid shooting m m's at the tree shooting
them nems and you're right we're [ __ ]
running and picking them up
you would love all that stuff okay let
me put it through this way yes i would
and i agree with you sorry i had parents
that loved me and had a disposable
income
how to make our channels i didn't spend
all the money on [ __ ] marlboro lights
okay i had to make my own racial rocket
with a hair tie and a [ __ ] and a
broken fork
um no and i agree with you 100
so this goes into like this goes into my
argument with you of like do you bro
above ground cool pool's better than an
in-ground pool it's like that's just
that's just you making this up yes i i
do do that as deflection but i'll be
honest with you sure in this case yeah
dude if i had like if i had the red
rider bb gun on my back and i was like
you know skateboarding and like setting
things on fire down the street sure call
me a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] but i was a
nice wholesome kid in the woods just
said building a tree house no don't act
like you were out there with the [ __ ]
cub scouts come on i was i was in a
steal of lumber to make [ __ ] half
pipes with your [ __ ] dirtbag buddies
who may or may not have been sniffing
gas
glue and i'm aware that i do do that i'm
saying sure but i want to say this that
whenever i had chinese stars i never had
chinese stars [ __ ] what are you kidding
me say oh you're a bit i had i had like
a an american wholesome slingshot you're
playing with this [ __ ]
this [ __ ] this international chinese
star [ __ ] mine was american
american made you're working for the
enemy here's the thing i put those all
in the same category whenever i had the
chinese stars of the fireworks or any of
that
i always felt like i was doing something
wrong
can i say that
sure that's just because you're [ __ ]
mentally warped that's not my problem
the [ __ ] father father steve got to
you kids got a point
felt like you're doing something wrong
never had a chinese star huh see that
goes i could lump that in with all that
crap no that would have been a mic i was
a i had i had like it was like a
christmas story had the red rider bb gun
he was a good kid
uh i see more buzz vibes out of you no
not at all really yeah no
i was a wholesome boy
wholesome wrist rocket
yeah it's a slingshot what i mean what
do you think i'm like doing bank jobs
and [ __ ] with it it's a [ __ ] sleep
i was in the woods with like a [ __ ]
pebble okay all right
all right i just said on paper that
sounds like the i think that's your
internals if you were playing bully the
video game those are the things you
would go around to collect yeah get over
here i'll give you a wedgie all right
yeah you're nuts that's crazy
all right
weigh in on this
the the anxiety for the illegal throwing
stars is hilarious you're like i feel
like what's wrong with these illegal
fireworks throwing stars
is way more dangerous than than a
slingshot really way more dangerous all
right so i'm the bad kid
yeah there you go yeah when's the last
time you saw a ninja with a [ __ ] with
a slingshot exactly what bad guy has a
slingshot
but proper criminals have your weapons
chinese you were a pyro i did i didn't
hit the neighbor with the chinese star
once
yeah
and i'm a piece of she said pieces [ __ ]
he owed me money
oh man i'm kidding my cousin found it
and threw it into the woods
cause it was bad
man the catholic guilt in your family is
something else ripe with it
layered it's like a five bean burrito
there's a kid in the woods in bluebell
with a throwing star and fully prints on
it somewhere yeah yeah yeah probably
getting ready you're going to get set
it's a setup too you better go find that
throwing star
i got my dna all over it oh jesus christ
cause i used to jerk off on it
i thought that was a fun twist
nobody came with me you got to go to
confession
um i did go to confession a couple weeks
ago he had no time for me
what'd you say
uh did you apologize for being rude to
your best pal i hadn't done that yet you
do it every day what are you talking
about
nah he had no time for me i tried to get
into some things he he said yeah yeah he
gave me that he said go say a couple
hail marys and hit the bricks yeah
probably into the strip club or
something like that
oh god all right uh let's see let's
knock out a couple of moe here um
this one's a home run this is from reed
where you raised
sorry were you raised by your
grandparents even though both your
parents were alive and well
man that's that's a bad kid
that's a that's
that ain't great
if that kid's got a bb gun a slingshot
fireworks and throwing stars
my kids ain't going over there okay
there you go does that make sense yes
that makes sense see
we're on the same page we just came in
at it from did you have any friends
growing up
where the grandparents with that you
know where somebody was missing and
there was a third
an extended family member playing one of
the roles which it's it's not a trashy
thing it's a great thing that the other
family member stepped up and obviously
circumstances everything it's a trashy
thing but it's not classy that means
somebody's on the abu ghats on the junk
come on sure something's going on
they had them young they didn't know
yeah i mean this happened that happened
but it's still garbage sure i'm not
above it sure
many friends that had that situation
yeah tell you what though
they were always the best grandparents
they were
they were
they they were cooler and hipper than
some regular pants because they were
they were with kids every day they were
they had to
they they were with the youth my
grandfathers and they got these kids
every like seven years they were always
the fun ones that would like take you to
the movies sure you know what i mean
because they had because
you know
a lot of times the grandparents are a
lot easier on the grandkids than they
were on the kids sure you know because
now they're older they want to have fun
they want to do all the things that they
didn't get to do with the kids and that
that can really work to your advantage
you know somebody's
sure somebody's bob's in rehab for a
couple of weeks yeah there you go and
i'm the piece of [ __ ] kid taking
advantage of these poor people
look at you always like plus they always
cooked really well
yeah more 20 you know 30 more years of
experience and throwing down in the
kitchen no mom
can cook
oh you know in a vacuum no mom can cook
as good as a grandma yeah but then i
disagree with this because we were just
talking really we talked about this the
older we were talking about our parents
the older these broads get
oh yeah they start slipping yeah there's
there's a you should retire age sure
yeah yeah you should pass the recipe
down but the recipe's never as good as
the way she made it
but then the next this isn't making any
sense because you say
they shouldn't there's no grandmom
that's as good no mom is as good as a
grandma yes but at some point the
grandmom gets worse i don't understand
well yes i'm saying of course when
they're [ __ ] 90 years old and they
can't see the [ __ ] measuring spoons
yeah
thinking the salt's [ __ ] yeah so
don't you all right
[ __ ] try to contradict me i'm not i'm
just trying to get in my head oh man
what i'm also saying is too when it
comes to time where
you know she's not when the grandmom's
not making the casserole the mashed
potatoes they usually pass it down to
some bozo in the family
it's never it sounds very personal it's
never as good it sounds very very what
dish are you talking yeah this is
something
i'm talking about my mama shepherd's pie
i knew it i knew there was too much
emotion connected to this then
you trace i'm telling you right now you
ain't there yet
keep working on it
i know when you're talking here and
there's something [ __ ] still waters
run deep miami used to make a shepherd's
pie that would blow your [ __ ] air
back yeah on a crisp autumn day whip
that out on a saturday afternoon we'd
all come over we'd all go over
to have the shepherd's pie like four
families would converge on one house
shepherd's pie oh
i had an aunt that threw down banana
pudding oh and then everyone would ask
the rest of me and she go oh just follow
the box it's on the boxes
i got an ant who's oatmeal raisin
cookies
blow your shout out to aunt mindy
i know kyle's listening shout out to
aunt mindy
these cookies i'm not an oatmeal raising
guy come christmas time
three four five six of them at a time
everybody and she goes oatmeal raisins
like ginger ale every once in a while
that's all right she goes i ginger on
yesterday i know
diet didn't look too shallow
i've said it before you get the
cranberry around the holidays
screaming cold that ginger ale ties the
season in um but
uh
[ __ ] and she goes just it's off the box
it's off the bar and like at some point
another all the other ants right this
thing ain't off the [ __ ] box
something's up mindy and you ain't
telling us they're doubling up on
something some butter sugar or something
something that's cooking yeah and
they're not letting me in my aunt mary
owen one time made uh stuffing and she
did it real thin
and it was so crispy and so [ __ ] good
and i knew she did something to it but
she would never admit never tell anybody
what she what she did to make it so good
yeah oh that's what i'm saying man yeah
i know you can't compete with that
experience with that with the experience
of making it a million different sundays
in a row yeah
yeah i get yes of course i get that and
that's why sometimes
when the grandparents raise the kids it
works out for everybody sure sure sure
except for the kids mental health and
the parents
but i had a nice saturday
and in foleyville that's all that
matters when we get down to it
you enjoyed yourself to a degree yeah
there's aspects of that that i wouldn't
argue with
they also knock out breakfast too
and the house dress knocking out a
little brekkie doing sausages i feel
like that's when they get loose with it
that's when they start cutting some
corners like
i would much rat at this point
i would rather have
because now if we're looking
generational it's like my mom is the
grandmom and then
my sister and sister-in-law's would be
the
i'm not eating at your sister's house
i'll tell you that right now i'm going
to the pizza you are not invited to
either one of them i could get an invite
no you could couple years she's not a
fan really really wow she heard she you
she heard that you criticized for being
divorced you called her kid a piece of
[ __ ] kid did i you're you're out no
you're talking about the piece of your
sister both of them why would anybody
want to be around you fun guy
[Laughter]
judging everybody it's what you do
uh still what invite notwithstanding
if i'm using that right
i don't know i would much rather go to
the pieces for dinner than your sisters
no offense
because i know it's gonna be
a better meal
although my sister-in-law's
see this is what i'm saying you don't
know what you're talking about damn it
this guy's all over the place i need
more research he may so this is what he
does he thinks about a dish and then
makes a heart a hard statement on it
then thinks about another discus well
i'm not sure now i don't know i do like
her mashed potatoes my sister-in-law
puts out a meatball that
man second to none
unbelievable
but i still stand by my statement okay
um i think we can move on let's do one
or two more and then we're gonna wrap
her up what is the pieces dish have we
talked about this uh
if you're doing you're doing a contest
the family's life is on the line you get
to present one dish to the firing squad
that's either going to save yours or
break his
what are you putting out of denise to
peace
is it a cutlet
let's everything was uh it's tough i
honestly haven't because oh i know what
it might be what or bacon egg and cheese
i would say or breakfast really the only
yes that good because the only issue is
um
the past 10 years when i've been got
like you know whatever i've been up here
for eight years around she's out of
practice and i when i go home it's for
i'm not going home on like a tuesday
night and she's making dinner like when
i'm going home it's like oh we're going
here for dinner or i'm going home for
parties and stuff so i don't know her
the past eight years i've been out of
the loop on what's really cooking
she might have like a chicken cacciatore
or something that's ra everybody's
raving about yeah she she does me she
does make a [ __ ] killer string bean
casserole oh hiller kill that's good any
time of the year
as a mane or a side i don't give a [ __ ]
hillary's string being casual like a
green bean casserole i love it dude yeah
aunt niecy's taco dip is real big
anthony sees taco dip is a showstopper
it ain't like ain't mindy's cookies but
it's all right
that'll get you out of eastern europe
i'll tell you that throw it out in a
guard's face i'm saying i haven't had my
mom like i haven't had a proper dinner
cooked by my like she does thanksgiving
crushes thanksgiving for like 30 people
every year but like minus thanksgiving
i haven't had my mom's dinner in a long
time because we go back for
i go back for christmas easter
birthdays are typically in the summer
it's like a cookout barbecue like that
kind of stuff so it's never like
i haven't been home for like a [ __ ]
sunday meal of her like this is what i'm
making in probably 10 years before that
i wasn't living i like to get home on
the weekends every once in a while as
you know so you might see my pop um
patty patty dropped uh some fried green
tomatoes a couple weeks ago
wow yeah delicious yeah yeah i would go
my if on
i would put my mom's breakfast up with
most
most people i remember i learned when i
was like
eight my buddy matt his mom he like my
mom made him a bacon egg and cheese like
just an even real quickie on a couple of
two pieces of stroman and he was like
this thing
he's like what the [ __ ] is this thing
she can fry an egg
yeah april knows her way around a dozen
eggs my mom my mom's would be her
cutlets yeah just plain simple 4c cutlet
thin it's off the box it ain't off the
box you're doing something
i actually do know what her secret is
but i don't know if i could say it
okay
it's crisco uses crisco you know crisco
is
yeah you know what crisco is you have a
fried dad yeah you know what [ __ ]
crisco is
i'm from north carolina dog crisco you
dropped crisco like you were you were
talking about litecoin or something
well he was an nft yeah i know what
[ __ ] crisco is oh man they ran
commercials through the 90s
you know they spent millions of dollars
on everything make sure i know what
chris goes oh man that's a that's that's
that i'm sure that's frowned upon in
cooking these days but that stuff i'm
sure people still yeah yeah man nice tub
of lard
knock your socks off all right let's
wrap her up hang on real quick toby you
got me hungry now what's your mom's dish
dry martini
gang we love you kippy you got anything
for him guys uh come out to it we got a
couple of live shows left at the end of
the year we got a couple of live shows
come out to the [ __ ] live shows we
still got some decks of cards some
koozies left we'll get those out uh the
links everywhere the whole [ __ ] nine
yards join patreon.com thank you for the
[ __ ] support you guys are the [ __ ]
[ __ ] you've made this little pod that
could a [ __ ] bigger pod that could we
love you [ __ ] so much for [ __ ] you
know the army of garbage baby we love
you i want to say philly come out strong
october 27th helium comedy club and new
york city new york [ __ ] city come out
gotham comedy club that's they're both
going to sell the [ __ ] out november 9th
november 9th if you don't get your
[ __ ] tickets you're [ __ ] dumb skis
yeah it's gonna sell the [ __ ] out both
of those shows sold out come see us we
love you